[Musique]
et bien ce soir je souhaiterais parler
des problèmes sociaux et des problèmes
économiques et c'est pourquoi j'ai
demandé à monsieur georges le var et à
monsieur xavier marchetti de bien
vouloir me poser des questions dans ces
domaines alors oui ce genre glombard
commençait s'il vous plaît nous
approchons de la fin de la période de
lectorale en démocratie c'est toujours
l'occasion de dresser des bilans on
mesure tous ceux qui aiment qui reste à
faire
elles ont fait des promesses les
promesses elles viennent de partout vous
en faites aussi mais vous dites surtout
dans cette deuxième partie de la
campagne mais promesse je les tiens
comment tiendrez-vous toutes les
promesses que vous faites et bien
monsieur le var ya promesses promesses
d'un j'en connais qui promettent la lune
et qui nous ont pas montré vous avez
l'autre phase d'alu la phase cacher j'en
connais qui annoncent qu'ils diminueront
en deux ans ou en trois ans le budget de
15 mille milliards d'anciens francs et
va maintenant ils augmenteront toutes
les allocations et toutes les
gratifications distribuées ici ou là moi
je ne fais pas ce genre de promesses
j'ai en réalité fait deux choses j'ai
défini les objectifs politiques dans
certains domaines je parle de domaine
économique des domaines sociaux des
lignes politiques
et puis d'autre part je fais quelques
promesses précises il s'agit en
particulier des travailleurs
indépendants des artisans des
commerçants dans différents domaines
fiscaux et autres
il s'agit aussi du problème des
rapatriés et de quelques autres de
détail et ses promesses je les ai
chiffrait je vois dire d'ailleurs que
les chiffres je peux les aider défendre
puisque monsieur duhamel dans une
émission
radiodiffusée surimpose périphériques
étaient arrivés aux mêmes chiffres que
moi de l'ordre de 150 à 170 milliards
d'anciens francs par an j'ai vu il est
vrai que les interlocuteurs de monsieur
poher a simplement ajouté 1-0 il ya
bonjour oui enfin ça c'est les formes
modernes de la polémique
j'ai donc fait des promesses précises et
ses promesses je les tiendrai et
j'estime pouvoir les tenir dans le cadre
budgétaire actuel
vous vous présentez aussi comme l'homme
du dialogue et plus précisément en
matière sociale vous préconisez le
développement des négociations
paritaires
c'est effectivement un excellent moteur
du progrès social
mais ce n'est pas le seul l'état a aussi
son rôle à jouer
comment d'une façon générale le voyez
vous la répartition des efforts de
l'état et la place des négociations
paritaires et plus précisément encore
puisque vous avez lancé l'idée très
actuel est excellente dans l'économie
moderne et dans les entreprises
développer de la mensualisation
comment voyez-vous sa mise en oeuvre et
notamment à propos du smig alors sur ce
point je vous dirai ceci n'est ce pas le
rôle de l'état est à la fois d'être un
incitateur à ces négociations paritaires
autrement dit il ne doit pas être
indifférents et attendent que les
syndicats et le patronat se met face à
face l'un à l'autre il faut au contraire
qu'ils lisent push vous avez c'est ce
que j'avais fait par exemple en 1967 à
propos du chômage partiel
bon j'ai donc l'instant l'intention de
reprendre cette même position par
exemple en ce qui concerne la
mensualisation
c'est à dire le passage du salaire
horaire au salaire mensuel
progressivement bien entendu d'autre
part l'état est lui-même patron et dans
ce cas là les négociations paritaires
elles sont entre lui même et ses
employés c'est un deuxième rôle de
l'état et puis il ya un troisième qui
consiste à
dans ses responsabilités juridiques
c'est à dire par exemple s'agissant du
smig c'est à lui à définir le smig à le
fixer
je pense que si nous avions un progrès
la notion de mensualisation par exemple
si cette mensualisation se révéler dans
un certain nombre de branches
d'industrie acceptés par les uns et par
les autres et par conséquent un progrès
social qui ne comporterait pas de gêne
économiques extrêmes eh bien je ne vois
vraiment pas pourquoi l'état ne
généraliserait pas la mensualisation en
la lah en faisant un smig mensualisés un
smic mensuel
pour ma part même a priori j'en suis
tout à fait partisan je voudrais d'abord
que les négociations se soit ouverte et
qu'un premier échange de vues et eu lieu
pour me donner exactement l'impression
qu'ils économique en même temps que le
sentiment sociale parlons de grenelle si
vous le voulez bien à l'an passé vous
avez fait d'importantes concessions
augmenter le smic de 30 5% à paris
cela ne s'était jamais vu mais c'était
le prix qu'il a fallu payer pour
rattraper une longue stagnation de son
pouvoir d'achat et donc de souffrance de
travailleurs défavorisés de leur famille
pourquoi avoir tant attendu que comptez
vous faire pour dans l'avenir améliorer
progressivement la situation des
travailleurs défavorisés sur le smic
voyez vous nous aurons pourrions avoir
une très longue discussion et vous la
connaissez bien
d'abord on ne pouvait pas dire qu'il y
avait diminution de son pouvoir d'achat
puisque le smic était indexé sur le prix
de la vie ce qu'on reprochait au smig
c'est qu'il ne suivait pas la
progression du pouvoir d'achat des
autres saleh d'autre part vous le savez
il y avait là il n'y avait pas toujours
accords au sein même du gouvernement sur
la conception du smig et la conception
qui était celle du ministère des
finances consistait au fond à faire que
plus personne ne soit payée au smic
il y avait une autre conception qui
était de faire du smi
une garantie sociale un salaire de base
obligatoire et qui existe réellement
c'est celle qui a prévalu à grenelle en
effet alors si l'on veut éviter qu'il y
ait de nouveaux retards du smi par
rapport aux autres salaires je pense que
la solution la plus simple serait
d'index et ce smig non plus sur le prix
de la vie mais sur l' indice moyen de
hausse des salaires dans l'industrie
privée
c'est une question qui demande un peu
d'études mais qui ne me paraît pas a
priori à rejeter ça n'aurait pas
d'ailleurs toujours une malheureusement
une incidence très importante
néanmoins je crois que ce serait une
amélioration sensible dans un tout autre
domaine les questions de liberté
syndicale de droit syndical sont
toujours très actuel est source de
difficultés voire même d'inquiétude
une nouvelle loi se met en place depuis
la fin de l'année dernière c'est celle
sur la section syndicale d'entreprise
quelle sera votre attitude pour le
développement et l'application de cette
loi eh bien écoutez si un domaine où je
n'ai pas à rougir de ma propre action de
l'action personnelle
c'est dans ce c bien celui là car
lorsque à grenelle on a parlé du
problème du droit syndical dans
l'entreprise de la présence syndicale
dans l'entreprise et que les discussions
entre les syndicats d'une part le
patronat d'autre part se sont engagés
j'avais précisé que mon gouvernement
prendrait en cette matière
une attitude positive et qu'il
déposerait un projet de loi est un
projet de loi qui consacrerait
l'existence le droit à l'existence du
syndicat dans l'entreprise
c'est ce projet de loi je crois
pratiquement que le gouvernement de
monsieur couve de murville a mis au
point et a fait adopter par le parlement
et je le considère malgré tout un peu
comme mon fils et je crois que c'est une
date importante dans l'évolution des
rapports entre patronat et sadi
k et dans l'existence et la capacité
d'action du syndicalisme en france
je voudrais préciser encore le problème
comme premier ministre vous avez reçu de
nombreuses délégations syndicales
vous avez présidé des réunions les
représentants syndicaux que vous aviez
en face de vos étaient des hommes
absolument libre vis-à-vis de vous comme
des employeurs d'ailleurs et il pouvait
donc en toute tranquillité d'esprit
défendre fermement le mandat qu'ils
avaient reçus de leurs organisations
c'est une situation la situation dans
les entreprises est tout à fait
différente car là les délégués syndicaux
demeurent les subordonnés les salariés
de l'europe ou ailleurs et par
conséquent ils sont dans une position
beaucoup plus difficile dans d'autres
pays ils sont mieux protégés qu'en
france même depuis le vote de la loi sur
la section syndicale d'entreprise
accueilli auriez-vous par exemple de
manière favorable des propositions
s'inspirant de certains précédente
législation étrangère
vous savez aussi bien que moi je le var
que notre législation protège déjà les
délégués syndicaux en ce sens que un
patron ne peut pas licencier un délégué
syndical sans avoir un avis conforme de
l'inspection du travail l'accord de
l'inspection du travail
il est vrai que il le fait quelquefois
sans avoir cet avis mais dans ce cas là
il y as poursuites judiciaires et le
patron est condamné à indemnité je sais
qu'il ya des pays où on va plus loin et
ou appareils en impose la réintégration
par exemple je crois que ceci peut
s'imaginer mais que dans l'état actuel
de la situation sociale en france ça me
paraît encore tout de même
fissile pour une bonne raison c'est que
nous avons une pluralité syndicale
extraordinaire nous avons cinq six sept
syndicats quelquefois dans une
entreprise et ne pouvons pas considérer
que chaque fois qu'un salarié est
licencié pour une raison qui n'a rien à
voir avec sa fonction de délégué
syndical on doit obligatoirement le
réintégrer je crois que nous sommes
obligés à une certaine prudence
mais il va de soi et d'ailleurs j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire aux dirigeants du
cnpf très fermement
il va de soi que l'inspection du travail
à des consignes très sévère pour
surveiller sur ce point ce qui se passe
et doit en avoir et d'autre part aussi
qu'on peut peut-être imaginer
d'un point de vue juridique aller vers
le tueur de magistrature social qui
serait chargée de traiter ce genre de
questions et qui par là même aurait
peut-être d'une autorité supérieure à
celle des tribunaux ordinaires
vous avez déclaré à diverses reprises
que vous étiez favorable à ce que les
différentes familles ou tendances de
l'opinion
et puis s'exprimer à la rtf je pose une
question est ce que cela vaut aussi pour
les organisations syndicales
je ne vois pour ma part aucun
inconvénient bien au contraire à ce que
sur les antennes de la rti la télévision
en fait il y ait des discussions entre
les représentants des syndicats et des
représentants de l'état ou des
représentants du monde économique du
patronat qu'il y ait des débats
économiques et sociaux chacun peut
s'exprimer et je vous le dis très
franchement je voudrais tout de même
demandé aussi un peu de pitié pour les
téléspectateurs n'est ce pas je ne
voudrais pas qu'à propos de cette
mauvaise querelle que certains fonds
alloués rtf il j'ai l'impression qu'ils
seront quandalle est désormais à une
télévision on ne parlera plus que
politique que questions économiques que
questions sociales et que du soir au
matin les grandes idées seront débattues
et on leur expliquera ce qu'il faut
penser dans tous les domaines
l'odf a pour mission sans aucun doute
d'informer elle a aussi promis sion
d'éduquer mais dans tous les domaines et
non pas simplement dans cela et puis
elle a aussi pour mission de distraire
et je dois dire que si j'ai testé les
spectateurs après maintenant presque
trois mois de campagne politique
j'aspirais à voir des films même des
western dans une précédente émission au
1er tour vous adressant aux agriculteurs
vous avez montré une attention et une
connaissance très grande de leurs
problèmes je n'ai pas le sentiment qu'il
en aille exactement de même avec les
problèmes du monde ouvrier difficultés
de logement panier de la ménagère
toujours difficile à remplir
formation professionnelle toujours
insuffisante en nombre et parfois en
qualité problème de l'emploi
comment ferez vous pour assurer le
progrès de la situation de cette partie
importante de la population
c'est quelque chose que j'ai lu bien des
fois n'est ce pas il se trouve en effet
que fils d'universitaires même
d'instituteurs petit fils de paysan
on me dit mais vous n'êtes pas fils ni
petit fils d'ouvrier
c'est vrai c'est vrai je crois pourtant
avoir deux des problèmes de la vie des
salariés dans les agglomérations de la
vie les ouvriers la vie quotidienne de
l'ouvrier elle sa femme
je crois avoir une impression et une
impression réaliste et précise il
m'arrive souvent d'aller prendre l'avion
par exemple de bonne heure le matin ou
tard le soir et de voir ses salariés ses
employés qui gagnent paris ou quittent
paris par des moyens transports et
jeunes dit mon dieu
une heure de train ou de métro ou
d'autobus et puis 8 9 heures de travail
et puis recommencer une heure de train
de métro d'autobus
ce n'est pas une vie agréable
c'est une vie certainement pénible et
que je ressens pont profonde et et
figurez vous que je crois avoir dit mais
je ne sait plus à quelle occasion
c'était peut-être sur un poste
périphériques
je m'en excuse auprès de erdf je crois
avoir dit que l'amélioration de la vie
du salarié de sa famille de sa femme
c'était sans aucun doute un problème de
dignité de rapports dans l'entreprise de
droit syndical
mais c'était avant tout un problème de
vie quotidienne de prix de la vie
précisément de logements de logements
confortables comme mode de transport
rapide et facile et pas trop cher de
crèches pour que la ménagère puisse
mettre ses enfants dans une crèche
tranquillement est allée elle même soit
faire ses courses soi travail et c'est
cet environnement de la vie du salarié
et de sa famille qui me paraît en effet
très important
et quant au domaine de l'emploi ou la
formation professionnelle j'en vois
aussi l'importance d'une façon générale
est permanent mais alors permettez-moi
de vous rappeler qu'en ce domaine
mon gouvernement sait faire de très
grands progrès là
formation professionnelle même s'il est
encore insuffisante et que en ce qui
concerne l'emploi le chômage le chômage
partiel
nous avons aussi fait beaucoup et incité
le patronat à faire beaucoup et qu'on a
même abouti à des accords qui je crois
donne satisfaction vient de dire que
vous connaissez parfaitement les
problèmes agricoles
c'est vrai il ya longtemps que nous en
occuper et le gonflement du budget de
l'agriculture lors de votre passage à
l'hôtel matignon prouve que vous êtes
toujours attaché à l'avenir de
l'agriculture
vous en avez beaucoup parlé dans cette
campagne et vous êtes beaucoup attachée
à la défense des exploitations
familiales
celle qui a le plus de peine à vivre
parce que les petits parce qu'elle est
mal équipée parce qu'elle n'est pas dans
le mouvement du progrès économique et
chaque fois que vous êtes vous avez pris
la défense de la détestation familiale
j'avoue qu'une question m'est venu à
l'esprit c'est celle ci est ce que vous
êtes sincère est ce que vous êtes un
serbe en tant qu'homme et pas seulement
en tant que candidat écoutez monsieur le
var à l'instant disait on voit que vous
êtes descendants l'agriculteur et
comment voulez vous je ne sois pas
sincère je suis d'un pays où ce problème
est absolument le problème quotidien et
le problème de beaucoup de gens qui sont
encore de ma famille croyait le alors je
ne suis pas du tout d'avis que la petite
exploitation familiale soit condamné je
crois le contraire je crois simplement
qu'il faut que les surfaces soit plus
grande
je crois qu'il faut que l'organisation
le groupement permet une meilleure
utilisation d'équipements collectifs au
lieu d'avoir des investissements qui
charge individuellement trop chaque
exploitation et je crois en plus que non
seulement économiquement c'est viable
mais encore mais encore que c'est
socialement nécessaire et que nous ne
pourrons pas transformer la france en
désert et que géographiquement ça n'est
pas rationnel
les etats unis le canada l'argentine
sont d'immenses espaces où il est normal
comme d'ailleurs dans le bassin parisien
que nous ayons ces grandes propriétés
cette exploitation industrielle
comment voulez-vous faire ça dans le
pays de bocage ou de montagne ça n'est
pas adapté au sol ce n'est pas adapté à
notre rats
et ça serait politiquement et
socialement très fâché alors le problème
c'est d'arriver avant tout ça rentable
je crois pour ma part que c'est viable
et que c'est rentable à condition que
certaines mutations sa complice et ses
mutations que j'essaie d'encourager par
ce gonflement du budget de l'agriculture
en même temps que je sais les rendre
moins douloureuse en particulier en
matière sociale par la part de l'état
dans les subventions pour les la
sécurité sociale des agriculteurs en
bresse et quelle est votre conception du
progrès social du progrès économique
est-ce que vous agirez au coup par coup
ou es ce que vous avez une conception
plus général 1
un projet à un programme et de quelle
façon entendez vous mettre cela en
oeuvre un gouvernement doit avoir d'une
part l'adaptation à la réalité c'est ce
que vous appelez le coup par coup et il
doit d'autre part avoir un objectif est
ce que vous me demandez si je comprends
bien c'est qu'elle est un peu la
conception de la société qui est en moi
ns pas et des rapports sociaux
eh bien on a employé différents termes
le général de gaulle apparaît
associations puis il a parlé de
participation le mot ont d'ailleurs fait
peur à certains n'ont pas griser les
autres je crois que tout cela recouvre
néanmoins une certaine idée et cette
idée c'est qu'il faut arriver d'une part
à sauver la liberté qui est un bien
fondamente d'autre part assurer un
minimum d'égalité c'est à dire aider les
plus défavorisés les salaires les plus
bas
les catégories les plus malheureuses à
s'élever et aboutir un niveau de vie
convenable et ensuite que dans les
rapports sociaux
il y un véritable dialogue est une sorte
de nouveau contrat social que les gens
sachent pourquoi ils travaillent
quelle est la raison d'être
travail que chacun ait sa part de
responsabilité et même d'initiative et
qu'il se crée ainsi entre les hommes que
ce soit les patrons les cadres les
ouvriers que ce soit les classes
sociales dans leur ensemble des rapports
qu'ils soient nouveaux et qui soient
fondées ou non pas sur l'amour je ne
voudrais pas transférés au gouvernement
les possibilités où les pouvoirs de la
religion et le aimez vous les uns les
autres de l'évangile mais qui soient
fondées sur le respect humain sur le
respect de l'autre sur le respect
toujours de la personne humaine et que
chacun sache qu'un homme est un homme et
qu'à ce titre il a droit au respect de
ses semblables
quelles que soient les situations que
les a occupés par rapport aux coûts plan
économique puisqu'il faut y venir
si vous voulez bien nous allons
continuer avec l'agriculture vous avez
dit que vous êtes persuadé que la petite
exploitation familiale a un avenir mais
est-ce que d'après vous il en a un dans
le cadre européen car s'ils considèrent
les propositions faites à bruxelles et
notamment le fameux prend mal salt qui
veut rendre en free remettre en friche
environ la valeur de guy départements
français qui veut envoyer à la batte à
trois millions et demi de vaches qui
produisent trop de beurre et c'est
acceptable si on suit ses conceptions
européennes qui sont malgré tout celle
de la commission de bruxelles
peu ou prou comment la petite
exploitation peut-elle s'intégrer dans
un système pareil
et en ce qui vous concerne
personnellement est-ce que vous admettez
ce plan marshall même pour le problème
fondamental qu'il pose france qui compte
à savoir est-ce qu'on peut laisser
l'agriculture européenne coûté 1000
milla ancien puits 5000 milliards dans
dix ans pour résorber ses excès dans
tout d'abord n'est ce pas
je crois que il faudrait que on pose à
l'échelle européenne les problèmes plus
largement et qu'en particulier on se
préoccupe de ce qui peut être la base
même d'une communauté économique
c'est-à-dire de la priorité donnée aux
productions de cette communauté en vous
savez qu'à l'heure actuelle par exemple
en matière de corps gras
il ya une augmentation vertigineuse des
importations par exemple de soja
américain
eh bien peut-être est il pas normal de
dire que nous produisons trop de corps
gras et dans lé importé des états unis
qui ont bien autre chose a exporté que
du soja ensuite le plowman seul c'est
bien gentil de vouloir mettre en friche
et terre française
et bien non je n'admets pas que monsieur
mansholt nous met en friche les terres
françaises et le gouvernement français
sur ce point là sera catégorique joule
garantie si c'est moi qui suis président
de la république et c'est la
démonstration d'ailleurs la nécessité
d'un gouvernement qui est une autorité
même sur le plan international et qui
soit capable de résister à des pressions
même si ces pressions s'appuie sur des
raisons financières ou économiques qui
ne sont pas sans valeur je l'admets bien
au plan intérieur alors maintenant est
ce que vous ne pensez pas que la
première de toutes les questions qui a
des répercussions d'ailleurs social sur
le bien-être et les français c'est
l'impôt vous avez dit souvent vous même
que nous avons atteint en france un
maximum intolérable actuellement dexim
tolérable à genève tu fais pour moi il
est je crois presque intolérable
arrivons à une prélèvement de 40% sur le
produit national brut
on peut dire c'est plus de l'impôt ça
commençait de la rapide alors si vous
êtes au pouvoir
qu'est ce que vous allez faire dans ce
domaine est allé nous fait allez vous le
faire tout de suite je ne suis
certainement pas pour une grave à une
aggravation de lumpp il n'en est pas
question
est ce si je ne prends pas en tant que
candidat j'parle comme vous même en tant
que économistes et d'un point de vue
social aussi je crois que la surcharge
fiscale est devenue lourde et qu'elle a
besoin en effet d'être
atténué mais je crois aussi que cette
surcharge fiscale vous savez est presque
égal dans les pays voisins
alors je suis partisan de certaine
diminution de l'impôt là où il est trop
lourd mais je crois que au total c'est
plutôt un problème de répartition de
l'ain pourri qu'il faudrait probablement
repenser notre système fiscal
le rock à la fois plus équitable moins
contraignant pour le contribuable est
peut-être plus juste je dirais même
certainement plus juste bien nous avons
parlé un peu d'agriculture il faut tout
même parler un peu de l'industrie
puisque c'est la vie même de ce pays on
peut qu'on peut dire que nos entreprises
ne sont pas tellement bien placé une
rêverie et nos cadres sont ceux qui
travaillent le plus en avant mais nos
entreprises sont celles qui font le
moine bénéfices elles n'investissent pas
assez
or l'investissement c'est l'avenir ce
que je voudrais savoir très brièvement
sait si vous avez en tête une véritable
politique industrielle
eh bien oui je veux une politique
industrielle et d'ailleurs j'ai déjà dit
à une époque où je n'étais pas candidat
j'ai déjà dit qu'il fallait que nos
entreprises et des marges bénéficiaires
supérieures est d'ailleurs en bleu a
reproché en disant que je faisais le jeu
des truste et bien non il ne s'agit pas
d'être riche tout d'être est comme on
voudra il s'agit en réalité de permettre
à nos entreprises de d'être productive
et d'être compétitive et cela suppose
et bien cela suppose que tout
l'environnement qu'il s'agit des
équipements collectifs qu'il s'agit du
système et des contraintes
administratives qu'il s'agit du système
fiscal
les pousse à investir au dieu les
pousser à stagner ou à trop distribué
peut-être quelques fois à leur propre
propriété
c'est tout un système a repensé et pour
ma part ce sera une mais préoccupation
première
si j'ai à former le gouvernement donc
pour l'industrie vous avez un grand
projet alors je suppose qu'une fois à
rivaliser si vous êtes élu vous allez
être un président qui suit de très près
les affaires économiques du pays est ce
que vous allez intervenir pour inspirer
animé et voir contrôler le
loca économique de ce pays je pense que
dans les circonstances actuelles les
problèmes économiques et sociaux sont
pour la france de première importance et
que sont les plus urgents et que par
conséquent ce sera demain le rôle du
chef de l'état d'animer une politique
dans ce domaine et de l'inspirer ce qui
ne veut pas dire que ce sera son domaine
réservé bien entendu bien l'on veut nous
à la question qui prime toutes les
autres actuellement mon avis en dehors
des questions sociales qui sont parfois
douloureuses
c'est la monnaie ça ne va pas très fort
de ce côté là encore nous avons perdu
beaucoup de nos réserves de devises
ce conte son passé 34 milliards à des
humiliations 18 mois de francs nouveau
bien sûr notre commerce extérieur se
dégrade et notre or continue à s'en
aller
d'autre part le billet de 100 francs ne
vont plus à l'étranger que 90 francs
dans ces cas là on a parfois intérêt à
faire un ajustement et on a intérêt à le
faire qu'en arrivant au pouvoir plutôt
qu'à prier allant propose une question
précise et directe
est ce que vous envisagez de dévaluer
écoutez je vois qu'ils étaient vous êtes
journaliste et économiste
alors vous savez que la tradition des
gouvernements c'est à dire qui ne
dévalue rompt pas la veille du jour il
évalue par conséquent vous ne vous
attendez pas à une réponse positive en
ce domaine bien entendu mais et je
voudrais essayer de prendre le problème
sous un angle un peu plus large
je crois que le problème de notre
monnaie et notre situation d'ailleurs
financière dans son ensemble n'est pas
si grave qu'on le dit je crois qu'il ya
enfin le compte que le fond est solide
mais il y a deux aspects il ya d'une
part un problème de confiance
il ya d'autre part un problème
international problème de confiance
il faut que l'état par sa stabilité
politique par les hommes qui sont au
gouvernement par l'ape la politique
qu'ils afficheront en matière économique
et financière inspire confiance et que
c'est un peu ce qui a manqué à certaines
occasions et en second lieu il faut
aussi envisager la sphère sous l'ongle
internationale il est évident qu'à
l'heure actuelle tout le monde
occidental est un peu d'inflation
nous parlons du hausse des prix en
france de l'ordre de 6% mais les états
unis sentent eux à une hausse de 5% ce
qui pour eux est tout à fait inactif
mais et certaines monnaies étrangères
sont certainement dans des rapports qui
ne sont pas non plus tout à fait normaux
je crois donc qu'en dehors du problème
de la confiance intérieur il faudra
aller à une un accord international
dans tous ces domaines financiers de
confiance alors une petite question la
dernière sans malice d'ailleurs je
voudrais vous demander si vous estimez
honnêtement au fond de vous-même que
votre présence au pouvoir au mois de
novembre dernier encore puisque meunier
plus aurait suffi à maintenir la
confiance dans ce pays et à éviter la
fuite de capitaux que nous avons connu à
cette époque
comment voulez vous je réponde à une
pareille question n'est ce pas si je
disais non j'aurais l'air de me
condamner ci gisait wii jeux seraient
véritablement d'une prétention excessive
je crois simplement pouvoir dire que ma
présence au pouvoir demain devrait en
ces matières matières monétaires et
financières inspirait confiance non
seulement aux milieux économiques
mais à tous les petits épargnants
français et que parmi tous les hommes
qui m'ont apporté leur appui
il y a aussi d'autres 47 confiance et
que tout cela réuni devrait permettre
devrait nous permettre de franchir les
prochaines étapes en la matière sans
trop de difficultés
[Musique]